شرطه الانترنت قادمه تحذير تصدر عناوين
مجله البريطانيه التي نشرت تقريرا نبه الى
تبعات التشريعات التي اقرتها دول حول
العالم تحت زريعه حمايه المستخدمين من
المحتوى الضار والمعلومات المضلله على
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي المجله قالت ان
المجالس التشريعيه لولايات امريكيه
ومحاكمها ترسم خطوطا جديده حول حدود
التعبير حيث يتفق الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون على ضروره تغيير قواعد مراجعه
المحتوى على الشبكات الاجتماعيه لكنهم
يختلفون بشان ما يجب فعله حيال ذلك اما في
اوروبا فذهبت الهيئات التشريعيه الى ابعد
من ذلك اذ سيبدا العمل بقانون الخدمات
الرقميه للاتحاد الاوروبي دي اس اي الذي
تم اقراره في يوليو عام 2022 العام المقبل
في بريطانيا من المتوقع ان يتم سن قانون
السلام على الانترنت الذي تمت صياغته بعد
انتحار مراهق يبلغ 14 عاما بعد ان شاهد
مواد على الانترنت وتشير المجله الى ان
البرازيل اقرت قانون الاخبار الكاذبه الذي
يعاقب الشبكات الاجتماعيه لفشلها في تحديد
المعلومات المضلله كما ستعلن الهند عن
مشروع قانون تنظيم الانترنت في يونيو الذي
يقال انه سيحمل المنصات الاجتماعيه
مسؤوليه محتوى المستخدمين
المثير للقلق ان هذه التحركات تلهم
الحكومات في الاجزاء الاقل ديمقراطيه من
العالم لصياغه قواعد جديده خاصه بها
متابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات